There's vibe coding. That's what Andre Carpathie came up with. You don't look at the code and literally you're just building some kind of visual thing or maybe it's even a non-visual thing, but it has to have some kind of output in order for you to verify. And you never look at the code. Then there's rage coding. That's when vibe coding or this kind of coding goes poorly.
有一种“氛围编程”（vibe coding）。这是安德烈·卡帕西（Andre Carpathie）提出的概念。你不需要看代码，实际上你只是在构建某种视觉效果，或者甚至是非视觉的东西，但它必须有某种输出，以便你进行验证。你从不看代码。然后还有“愤怒编程”（rage coding）。那是当氛围编程或这类编程进展不顺时发生的情况。
And then you're just asking it to do something. This happened all the time with Claude 3.5 and 3.7. You'd ask it to do something. It would spin its wheels for a while and then it'd be like, you know what? The solution is we're deleting all those tests. We're going to get the test to work by deleting them, or we're just going to remove the file. The file's not there, now it works.
然后你只是要求它做某事。这种情况在 Claude 3.5 和 3.7 中经常发生。你会要求它做某事。它会转圈思考一会儿，然后它会说，你知道吗？解决方案是我们把那些测试全删了。我们要通过删除测试来让测试通过，或者我们干脆把文件删了。文件没了，现在它能运行了。
And that's rage coding, because it is so frustrating. It's like gaslighting you. It's like, oh, the test works. I know it doesn't, because you literally just output like it doesn't work. Anyways, the middle is guide coding. Guide coding is when you're pair programming with it. You really need to guide it where it's going, and it goes well. So we've all been there, except for Cloud 4.
这就是愤怒编程，因为它太令人沮丧了。它就像在对你进行煤气灯操纵（gaslighting）。它会说，哦，测试通过了。我知道它没通过，因为你刚才输出的结果明明显示它没通过。总之，中间地带是“引导编程”（guide coding）。引导编程是指你和它进行结对编程。你确实需要引导它前进的方向，这样进展就会很顺利。所以我们都经历过这些，除了 Claude 4。
Cloud 4, it's amazing, folks. It's amazing. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 249 recorded on August 21st, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about a plethora of topics, including some open source libraries, some podcast recommendations, our upcoming trip to Europe, and the upcoming trilogy of episodes with Sean Parent. All right. What should we talk about? Should we talk about the three bullets I sent? Or should we talk about AI things? Your choice, dealer's choice. We can talk about everything, but first, I need to open up. I actually wrote down a list of things to bring up.
Claude 4，它太棒了，伙计们。它太棒了。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，这是 2025 年 8 月 21 日录制的第 249 期节目。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们将讨论大量话题，包括一些开源库、一些播客推荐、我们即将到来的欧洲之行，以及即将推出的肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）三部曲系列节目。好了。我们该聊些什么？是聊我发的那三个要点？还是聊 AI 相关的事情？你选吧，听你的。我们可以聊任何事情，但首先，我需要开个头。我确实写下了一份要提的事情清单。
Things to bring up. Number one is I made a reference to the Dunkie GTA6 video in our last recording where they, I worked the clip graphics. Look at the graphics on these graphics. Look at the graphics on this graphics. It's not actually from the GTA6 donkey clip. It's from the Astrobot video. So if you went and looked for it and you were like, what's this guy talking about?
要提的事情。第一点是我在上次录音中提到了 Dunkie 的 GTA6 视频，我当时说“看看这些图形，看看这些图形”。其实那不是来自 GTA6 的 Dunkie 剪辑。它是来自 Astrobot 的视频。所以如果你去搜了，然后心想，这家伙在说什么呢？
The Astrobot is one of his best. Anyways, that's number one. Number two, Phineas, past guest on the pod when we went to that vegan restaurant in New York and then we went to the escape room afterwards and luckily he did not have to leave in the middle of the escape room his wife going into labor he pointed out that when we I was talking about the repetition memory you know system I knew it had a name I couldn't come up with it
Astrobot 是他最好的作品之一。总之，这是第一点。第二点，菲尼亚斯（Phineas），我们播客之前的嘉宾，当时我们去了纽约那家素食餐厅，之后又去了密室逃脱，幸运的是他不需要在密室逃脱中途离开去陪他妻子生产。他指出，当我谈到间隔重复记忆系统时，我知道它有个名字，但我当时想不起来。
he messaged me when he was listening to it and he said it's called I might actually mispronounce it Anki A-N-K-I that's the system of like you've got flashcards you discard the ones you know right away and then you keep on feeding to yourself the ones that you have trouble with so it had a name i knew that i just couldn't come up with it perhaps it says something about our natures but um i do and i do feel like every time we chat about i i encounter greater frustration than than you do like the latest thing was like i wrote some curse rules from a project like i told this thing like that by thing i mean i mean uh clod i told it you know if you want to run the the tests in this
他在听节目时给我发了消息，他说它叫——我可能会读错——Anki，A-N-K-I。那是那种你有抽认卡的系统，你把知道的卡片立刻丢掉，然后不断给自己喂那些你有困难的卡片，所以它确实有个名字，我当时只是想不起来。也许这说明了我们的性格，但是，嗯，我确实觉得每次我们聊到 AI，我遇到的挫折感都比你多。比如最近的一件事是，我为一个项目写了一些 Cursor 规则，我告诉这个东西——我说的“这个东西”是指 Claude——我告诉它，你知道，如果你想在这个仓库里运行测试。
repo. You got to use this script because the script like launches a container on a remote node that has the right hardware to test this thing. And you know what it kept doing when I asked it to make a change? It's just like I wrote this very clear cursor rule. I was like if you want to run the tests, you have to do this. And then like it just kept repeatedly not doing that when it wanted to run the tests. And I'm like, you don't understand. Why didn't you listen to the cursor rules? And It was just like, oh, I'm so sorry. You're absolutely right. I did just ignore what you told me.
你必须使用这个脚本，因为脚本会在远程节点上启动一个容器，该节点有正确的硬件来测试这个东西。你知道当我要求它进行更改时它一直做什么吗？我写了非常明确的 Cursor 规则。我说，如果你想运行测试，你必须这样做。然后它就反复地不这样做，当它想运行测试时。我就说，你不明白吗？为什么你不听 Cursor 规则？它就说，哦，我很抱歉。你是完全正确的。我确实忽略了你告诉我的话。
Wait, did you test that the cursor rule worked before you made it a cursor rule? What do you mean? I mean, cursor rules, in my experience, I don't use them much anymore because Cloud 4, it's Clot for Sonnet, to be precise. I know the Opus model's bigger, folks, but you need to be able to iterate quickly and interrupt the model. You can't do that with Opus and the big ones. Sonnet's the best.
等等，你在把它变成 Cursor 规则之前测试过它是否有效吗？你什么意思？我的意思是，根据我的经验，我不再怎么使用 Cursor 规则了，因为 Claude 4——准确地说是 Claude 3.5 Sonnet。我知道 Opus 模型更大，伙计们，但你需要能够快速迭代并打断模型。你用 Opus 和那些大模型做不到这一点。Sonnet 是最好的。
People keep asking, what do I use? It's Claude for Sonnet, best in the market. And in my experience, you shouldn't make a cursor rule until you find the golden path of what to say that gets it to do it correct all the time. Once you find that golden path, then shove it in a rule. This is like, I listen to like, oh, yeah, remind me to list off like six different new podcasts that I listen to all about dev AI tools and AI because I'm going through like a, that's not a midlife crisis. We just, I was an actuary at one point, then I was an engineer. I guess now I'm a software engineer still, but it's all AI. Anyways, it's all about context engineering.
人们一直问，我用什么？是 Claude 3.5 Sonnet，市场上最好的。根据我的经验，你不应该在找到能让它每次都正确执行的“黄金路径”之前就去写 Cursor 规则。一旦你找到了那条黄金路径，再把它塞进规则里。这就像，我听了，哦，对了，提醒我列出我听的六个关于开发、AI 工具和 AI 的新播客，因为我正在经历一个……那不是中年危机。我们只是，我曾经是一名精算师，然后是一名工程师。我想现在我仍然是一名软件工程师，但一切都是 AI。总之，这全是关于上下文工程。
So you have to figure out what is the, and that's literally the special sauce of all these frontier labs that are making these frontier models, foundation models, is they all have this like, you know, special incantation of words and whatnot that they whisper to these huge LLMs, and then based on how good that kind of context that they give it or the algorithms that they have for compressing that context so that you don't end up with like an ever-growing context
所以你必须弄清楚什么是……这正是所有制造这些前沿模型、基础模型的实验室的秘诀，他们都有这种，你知道，他们对这些巨大的 LLM 耳语的特殊咒语之类的东西，然后基于他们给它的上下文有多好，或者他们用来压缩上下文的算法，这样你就不会得到一个不断增长的上下文。
and the models go crazy. So the point of meaning, you can't just write a cursor rule and expect that it works. You've got to test out which one works best, find the golden path, then throw it in a cursor rule. So that's what I've been doing.
然后模型就会发疯。所以重点是，你不能只是写一个 Cursor 规则并期望它能工作。你必须测试哪一个效果最好，找到黄金路径，然后把它扔进 Cursor 规则里。这就是我一直在做的。
Because the only reason I've written cursor rules is like I've repeatedly run into it like not like every other chat or so. You know, it tries to run the tests in the wrong way and then I just tell it, no, no, no, you have to do this. And then like at your five times, I just put it into the cursor rule.
因为我写 Cursor 规则的唯一原因是我反复遇到它，比如每隔一个对话左右。你知道，它试图用错误的方式运行测试，然后我就告诉它，不，不，不，你必须这样做。然后，在五次之后，我就把它放进 Cursor 规则里了。
And it's just, it's like two seconds. sentences. Like, it should be able to figure it out. But, but it, uh, and then like a lot, I feel like my impression is a lot of times it does dumb shit. And you know what? When it does dumb shit, I get pissed. I understand. That's called rage coding. You know my three different categories, right? There's vibe coding. There's vibe coding. That's what Andre Carpathie came up with. That's the, you don't look at the code and literally you're just building some kind of visual thing or maybe it's even a nonvisual thing, but it has to have some kind of output in order for you to verify and you never look at the code then there's rage coding that's when vibe coding or this kind of coding goes poorly and then you're just asking it to do
这只是两句话。它应该能弄明白。但是，它……而且我觉得我的印象是，很多时候它会做蠢事。你知道吗？当它做蠢事时，我会很生气。我理解。那叫愤怒编程。你知道我的三个分类，对吧？有氛围编程。有氛围编程。那是安德烈·卡帕西提出的。那是，你不看代码，实际上你只是在构建某种视觉东西，或者甚至是非视觉东西，但它必须有某种输出以便你验证，而且你从不看代码。然后是愤怒编程，那是当氛围编程或这类编程进展不顺时，然后你只是要求它做……
something this happened all the time with cloud 3.5 and 3.7 you'd ask it to do something it would spin its wheels for a while and then it'd be like you know what the solution is we're deleting all those tests we're going to get the test to work by deleting them or we're just going to we're going to like remove the file the file's not there now it works and that's rage coding because it is so frustrating it's like gaslighting you it's like oh the test works I know it doesn't Because you just, you literally just output like it doesn't work. Anyways, the middle is guide coding. Guide coding is when you're pair programming with it.
某事。这种情况在 Claude 3.5 和 3.7 中经常发生。你会要求它做某事。它会转圈思考一会儿，然后它会说，你知道吗？解决方案是我们把那些测试全删了。我们要通过删除测试来让测试通过，或者我们干脆把文件删了。文件没了，现在它能运行了。这就是愤怒编程，因为它太令人沮丧了。它就像在对你进行煤气灯操纵。它会说，哦，测试通过了。我知道它没通过，因为你刚才输出的结果明明显示它没通过。总之，中间地带是引导编程。引导编程是指你和它进行结对编程。
You really need to guide it where it's going and it goes well. So we've all been there, except for Cloud 4. Cloud 4, it's amazing, folks. It's amazing. Speaking of that, I have to make a pitch to you. I don't, I'm actually, I don't believe that I need to make this pitch because I believe that it is the inevitable outcome of this. arc of like our career and life journeys and and i think i mentioned this to you like last time i
你确实需要引导它前进的方向，这样进展就会很顺利。所以我们都经历过这些，除了 Claude 4。Claude 4，它太棒了，伙计们。它太棒了。说到这个，我得向你推销一下。我其实不相信我需要做这个推销，因为我相信这是我们职业和人生旅程中不可避免的结果。而且我想我上次和你聊天时提到过这个。
chatted but uh i think inevitably you and i are going to have to uh build uh a small large language model uh like we're going to like it is the next step in our path down here which is like we're going to we're going to build one and we're going to do it live from the podcast I mean, sure. There's nothing we can't do, folks. You know why? We got Cloud 4. You know what?
但是，嗯，我认为不可避免地你和我将不得不构建一个小型大语言模型。就像，我们将要……这是我们在这条道路上的下一步，即我们将要构建一个，而且我们要在播客中直播完成它。我是说，当然。没有什么我们做不到的，伙计们。你知道为什么吗？我们有 Claude 4。你知道吗？
It doesn't matter what we need to do. We can do it now. Like, what did I? I'm not sure how closely you looked at that link that I sent you. But one of the things I've been trying to do is find real world thrust examples in the wild. And then, well, anyways, we'll just stop there. That's what I'm trying to do. GitHub search, infamously terrible.
我们需要做什么并不重要。我们现在可以做到。比如，我做了什么？我不确定你看了我发给你的那个链接有多仔细。但我一直在尝试做的一件事是在野外寻找真实的 Thrust 示例。然后，好吧，总之，我们就停在那儿吧。这就是我正在尝试做的。GitHub 搜索，臭名昭著的糟糕。
Well, we'll make this very long story short. But I spent the whole weekend. I was up till 630 on Saturday because I got back from a late 5K at 930 didn't go very well had a couple drinks with my buddy and then we got back at one and I had this idea as like you know what
好吧，我们长话短说。但我整个周末都在忙。我周六一直待到 6:30，因为我 9:30 从一个 5K 长跑回来，跑得不太好，和朋友喝了几杯，然后我们 1 点回来，我有了这个想法，就像，你知道吗？
I bet I could get some Claude4 scaffolding around GitHub search and find you know basically the top repositories ranked by GitHub stars or whatever and long story short you know come Monday I've got like three different versions of this it's absolutely beautiful
我打赌我可以用 Claude 4 在 GitHub 搜索周围搭建脚手架，找到，你知道，基本上是按 GitHub 星数排名的顶级仓库，或者其他什么。长话短说，你知道，到了周一，我已经有了三个不同的版本，它绝对漂亮。
like I don't know anything about GitHub search as API I know all about the rate limits now. We got $5,000 an hour if you're doing metadata on the repository. We got 10 a minute if you're doing code search. It's all garbage. And you know what? You can just start like, you know, scraping that stuff by hand. But the point being is now link in the show notes.
就像，我对 GitHub 搜索的 API 一无所知，我现在对速率限制了如指掌。如果你在做仓库元数据，我们每小时有 5000 次。如果你在做代码搜索，我们每分钟有 10 次。这全是垃圾。你知道吗？你可以直接开始，你知道，手动抓取那些东西。但重点是，现在链接在节目说明里。
Another vived project. We've got 2,000 repositories. Do you know what the number one repository? I mean, if you looked at it, you know. But do you know what the number? I looked at it briefly. I don't remember. The number one with 92,000 GitHub Stars.
另一个氛围项目。我们有 2000 个仓库。你知道排名第一的仓库是什么吗？我是说，如果你看了，你就知道。但你知道数字吗？我粗略地看了一下。我不记得了。排名第一的，有 92,000 个 GitHub 星。
This is just the one that it found. is Pie Torch. After that, it is phase? F-A-I-S, which comes from Facebook research. Then, actually, wait,
这只是它找到的那个。是 PyTorch。在那之后，是 FAISS？F-A-I-S，来自 Facebook 研究院。然后，等等，
this is the thrust colon-colon one. Did it update? Drop the Facebook research one because that was looking for thrust without the colon-colon.
这是 Thrust:: 的那个。它更新了吗？删掉了 Facebook 研究院的那个，因为那个是在找没有双冒号的 thrust。
And it has references to thrust in mark-down files and whatever, but it doesn't actually use it anymore. So anyways, number two, for actually using it is DMLC-S-X-E.
它在 markdown 文件里有对 thrust 的引用，不管怎样，但它实际上不再使用它了。所以总之，第二名，真正使用它的，是 DMLC-SXE。
G boost, and then number three, which is what I've been working on. Wait, wait, wait. I'm supposed to be looking at the thrust colon colon, colon, or the... Thrust colon, because that one is more accurate in terms of... Because thrust by itself comes up with like a lot of rocket or airplane, anything that involves the verb actually like thrust, takeoff, et cetera, will come up as a repository. Wait, wait, wait, wait, there's a bug here because when you go to it by default, it shows data set thrust colon colon, but the second result is the Facebook one.
XGBoost，然后第三名，就是我一直在做的。等等，等等。我应该看的是 Thrust::，还是……Thrust::，因为那个在……方面更准确。因为 thrust 本身会出现很多火箭或飞机，任何涉及动词“推力”（thrust）、起飞等的东西都会作为仓库出现。等等，等等，等等，这里有个 bug，因为当你默认进入它时，它显示的是 data set thrust::，但第二个结果是 Facebook 的那个。
Yes, I noticed that. So yeah, it says thrust colon colon, but doesn't actually load the correct data set. So you need to toggle on, toggle off. Listen, it worked for my purposes. I'll get Claude to fix it. You know, I'll get, Claude was doing a lot of work this weekend for me. We've got to give them a break. It's not perfect, but that's okay.
是的，我注意到了。所以是的，它说 thrust::，但实际上并没有加载正确的数据集。所以你需要切换开启，切换关闭。听着，它对我的目的来说有效。我会让 Claude 修复它。你知道，我会让……Claude 这个周末为我做了很多工作。我们得让它休息一下。它不完美，但这没关系。
We love you, Claude. Anyways, number three is paddle paddle, which is a parallel distributed deep learning framework. I have a theory about some of these, Connor. I have a theory about the one below cutlass. The one below cutlass, which is... We'll see if you... Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. But that's definitely correct. It's gonna... Wait, okay. It's called fly-by-wire sim slash aircraft. I just explained, though, that yes, that if you have like an airplane, you know, rocket ship one and they use the verb thrust, guaranteed the... I already looked it up. The namespace is auto-thrust. which has functions such as leg filter, washout filter, lead leg filter, time since condition.
我们爱你，Claude。总之，第三名是 PaddlePaddle，一个并行分布式深度学习框架。我有一个关于其中一些的理论，康纳。我有一个关于 Cutlass 下面那个的理论。Cutlass 下面那个，它是……我们看看你……哦，是的，是的，是的。但这绝对是正确的。它会……等等，好的。它叫 fly-by-wire sim/aircraft。但我刚才解释过，是的，如果你有像飞机、火箭那样的东西，它们使用动词 thrust，保证……我已经查过了。命名空间是 auto-thrust。它有诸如 leg filter、washout filter、lead leg filter、time since condition 等函数。
So it's clearly like some kind of engine thing. So it's not perfect. It's not perfect. But you know what? It's better than GitHub. I'm using GitHub, but GitHub itself is broken. Anyways, the point being, it's fantastic. So one of these I knew about, which is Uber's AresDB.
所以它显然是某种引擎之类的东西。所以它不完美。它不完美。但你知道吗？它比 GitHub 好。我正在使用 GitHub，但 GitHub 本身坏了。总之，重点是，它太棒了。所以其中一个我知道，就是 Uber 的 AresDB。
Yeah. I've known about that for a couple years that they use, that they use thrust. It's a real-time like analytics storage and a query engine. It's pretty cool. Yeah, I think you brought it up once on the podcast that Uber had their advanced technology group and they were making use of thrust. Yeah. But now we got a top 2000 list. And it's still not perfect.
是的。我已经知道那个好几年了，他们使用，他们使用 thrust。它是一个实时分析存储和查询引擎。它很酷。是的，我想你在播客上提到过一次，Uber 有他们的先进技术小组，他们在使用 thrust。是的。但现在我们有了一个前 2000 名的列表。而且它仍然不完美。
I haven't gone through and taken this all the way. But it was good enough to get me some repos that I had never heard of. And maybe we'll talk about the example that I'm working on right now is a. rank two array so a matrix and you want to do row wise mode computation so most frequent element row wise interesting problem we'll save it for another date uh we've only got a couple minutes left and then we're going to be interviewing sean so i will rattle off my podcasts actually i probably need my phone for this and uh and then we will be back afterwards because right now i think this is only going to be like 15 minutes.
我还没有把它全部过一遍。但它足以让我找到一些我从未听说过的仓库。也许我们会谈谈我目前正在处理的例子，是一个二维数组，也就是矩阵，你想做行向模式计算，即行中最频繁的元素。有趣的问题，我们留到下次再说。我们只剩下几分钟了，然后我们要采访肖恩，所以我将快速列出我的播客。其实我可能需要我的手机来做这个，然后我们之后会回来，因为现在我想这只会持续 15 分钟左右。
The podcast, if you are Claude Pilled or AI-pilled like me, and listen, folks, we all should be, is R. Actually, I should go in order. The Latent Space podcast is probably the best. It's called the AI Engineer podcast. I discovered them because they had Chris Latner on.
这个播客，如果你像我一样是 Claude 迷或 AI 迷，听着，伙计们，我们都应该这样，是 R。其实我应该按顺序来。Latent Space 播客可能是最好的。它叫 AI Engineer 播客。我发现他们是因为他们请了 Chris Lattner。
Anyways, that's a great. You should also listen to the big technology podcast. I don't actually know the guys are. I think they had someone on, and YouTube recommended to me, and so I added it to the Q. Cheeky Pint, which is hosted by John Collison, who I believe is the brother of Patrick Collison, who I believe is the CEO of Stripe, which is the payment company. I think he has some like C, insert O role at Stripe, but I don't actually know. So that's another one. The Dwar Keshe podcast, apparently this has been like a massive podcast that I just had never heard about, and the
总之，那是一个很棒的。你也应该听 Big Technology 播客。我其实不知道那些人是谁。我想他们请了某个人，YouTube 推荐给我，所以我就把它加到了队列里。Cheeky Pint，由 John Collison 主持，我相信他是 Patrick Collison 的兄弟，我相信他是 Stripe 的 CEO，那是一家支付公司。我想他在 Stripe 有某种 C 开头的职位，但我其实不知道。所以这是另一个。The Dwarkesh 播客，显然这是一个巨大的播客，我只是从来没听说过，而且
Open AI podcast, they have a podcast now. Obviously, they're going to be pretty biased. Training data, that's a Sequoia Capital podcast. They've had some bangers. And then I just added the, it was like the A16Z or something. Yeah, A16Z.
OpenAI 播客，他们现在也有播客了。显然，他们会非常偏颇。Training Data，那是红杉资本的播客。他们有一些很棒的节目。然后我刚加了，好像是 A16Z 还是什么的。是的，A16Z。
This one might be leaving the queue because they're another venture capital, but they're a little bit too venture capital for me, you know. I don't actually care about, I don't actually care about venture capital and, you know, private equity investments. I care about the, honestly,
这个可能会离开队列，因为他们是另一家风险投资公司，但他们对我来说有点太风险投资了，你知道。我其实不在乎，我其实不在乎风险投资和，你知道，私募股权投资。我关心的是，老实说，
latent space is the best. Anything close to latent space. So anyways, there's a list of podcast, folks. It's an amazing time to be alive. And my life is crazier and busier than it's ever been. I'm talking and traveling more than I ever have. And I'm also writing more code than I have the past two to three years. Like, in like, maybe I'm spending like a tenth of the
Latent Space 是最好的。任何接近 Latent Space 的东西。所以总之，这是一个播客列表，伙计们。这是一个活着的绝佳时代。我的生活比以往任何时候都更疯狂、更忙碌。我说话和旅行的次数比以往任何时候都多。而且我写的代码也比过去两三年多。就像，也许我花十分之一的
the time writing code and producing like the output that I used to when I was like 20 and writing code like 12 hours day. Yep. It's because you're not writing code anymore. You're managing AIs that write the code and you step in every once in a while. I'm an angry, I'm an angry AI manager. You're a happy one.
时间写代码，产生的输出却和我 20 岁时每天写 12 小时代码时一样。是的。这是因为你不再写代码了。你是在管理编写代码的 AI，你偶尔介入一下。我是一个愤怒的 AI 管理者。你是一个快乐的。
Yeah, you got to switch from rage coding to guide coding or vibe coding. I do a lot of both of the first two, not too much of the rage coding. Anyways, we've got to hop over. We're going to be interviewing Sean. so you got to wait a week. Well, actually, I guess you have to wait a week plus 10 minutes or half a long. Bryce and I record after this. But, yes, a week from now, you'll be hearing from Sean.
是的，你得从愤怒编程切换到引导编程或氛围编程。我做了很多前两种，愤怒编程不多。总之，我们得跳过去了。我们要采访肖恩，所以你得等一周。好吧，其实，我想你得等一周加 10 分钟或者多久。布莱斯和我在这之后录音。但是，是的，一周后，你就会听到肖恩的声音了。
I got to say, I got to say, it's a pity that Sean has left. Sean is the only person I know of his generation who is such a forward-looking take on, like, AI in the software space. So yes, let's pause here. So what's happened now? let me let me go get the numbers on this um ADSP so we you listener currently are listening to oh my god it's and that is great we didn't even plan that maybe I'm okay let me pause let me pause let me pause I'm too excited here folks so um you are currently listening to episode 249 you were just listening
我得说，我得说，肖恩离开了真是可惜。肖恩是我那一代人中唯一一个对 AI 在软件领域有如此前瞻性看法的人。所以是的，我们在这里暂停一下。那么现在发生了什么？让我……让我去拿这些数字，ADSP，所以你，听众，目前正在收听……天哪，它是……那太棒了，我们甚至没计划过。也许我……好吧，让我暂停，让我暂停，让我暂停。我太兴奋了，伙计们。所以，嗯，你目前正在收听第 249 期节目，你刚才听到的
to us before the record scratch that you heard a minute ago before talking with Sean then we then we had a chat an interview with Sean it's going to be split up into three parts it is I mean I'm not sure if it tops I don't think anything can top
是在我们录音之前，在你刚才听到的录音刮擦声之前，在与肖恩交谈之前。然后我们进行了一次与肖恩的聊天采访，它将被分成三部分。它是……我是说，我不确定它是否超过了，我不认为有什么能超过
the Steve Jobs you know was it a Porsche whatever car it was I think it was a Porsche I thought it was a Porsche yeah nothing can top that story but this is
史蒂夫·乔布斯，你知道，那是保时捷还是什么车，我想是保时捷。我以为是保时捷。是的，没有什么能超过那个故事，但这是
it's fantastic you know I think the first episode it's going to be mostly about Rust and then a little bit about AI the second episode's going to be about AI. And then the third episode is going to be about, like, the societal impacts and what we
太棒了，你知道，我认为第一集主要关于 Rust，然后一点关于 AI。第二集将关于 AI。然后第三集将关于，比如，社会影响以及我们
have to look forward to and not look forward to. It is fantastic, folks. I'm excited for you. And the reason I was saying is this is super exciting is because that's going to be episode 250, 51, and 52. So I might take, what do you think? Should we release the societal one? Because that, I mean, technically it would be out of order, but it would be kind of great
可以期待什么和不能期待什么。它太棒了，伙计们。我为你感到兴奋。我之所以说这超级令人兴奋，是因为那将是第 250、251 和 252 期节目。所以我可能会采取，你觉得呢？我们应该发布社会影响那一集吗？因为那个，我是说，从技术上讲它会乱序，但它会很棒
if our 250th episode is, it would be kind of great if our 250th episode is just getting Sean's thoughts on the societal implications of what's happening right now. I think, I think it'd be great. It's kind of a little bit out of order because it's going to start with me asking the question about whether his book, because he mentions he's working on the book, Better Code, and he makes an offhand remark whether, you know, it'll be necessary now in the age of AI, TBD. Anyway, so I filed this question in the back of my head.
如果我们的第 250 期节目是……如果我们的第 250 期节目只是获取肖恩对当前正在发生的事情的社会影响的看法，那会很棒。我想，我想那会很棒。它有点乱序，因为它将从我问他关于他的书的问题开始，因为他提到他正在写那本书，《Better Code》，他随口提了一句，你知道，在 AI 时代它是否还有必要，待定。总之，所以我把这个问题记在了脑后。
And then, yeah, just listening to his answer is, it's just very thought-provocative. And anyways, yes. It's interesting because I think his take was that he had a more optimistic take on the adoption. I'm maybe I'm just jaded after 10 or 15 years of being in the industry but I feel like
然后，是的，听他的回答，这非常发人深省。总之，是的。这很有趣，因为我认为他的观点是，他对采用率有更乐观的看法。也许我只是在行业待了 10 或 15 年后变得麻木了，但我感觉
change takes time and I feel like it won't be as rapid as people think because there will be lots of resistance I don't know like I'm starting to see
变革需要时间，我觉得它不会像人们想象的那么快，因为会有很多阻力。我不知道，就像我开始看到
now I think people are understanding that it for certain tasks is just like it's just rocket fuel like I was talking to a guy in a meeting on Monday
现在，我认为人们明白它对于某些任务就像火箭燃料一样。就像我周一在会议上和一个家伙交谈时，
who had bought what do they call it like one of those etching sketch kind of ink things where it's a low energy panel and and anyways had had like promised his wife a couple years ago that he was going to make a weather app out of it or whatever and anyways kind of it only gotten it half working and then boom he sick he sicked clot on it clod went and learned all the APIs he was like oh make sure you do it for free got a bunch
他买了他们称之为那种蚀刻草图之类的墨水屏东西，那是一个低能耗面板，总之，几年前答应他妻子他要用它做一个天气应用之类的，总之，只做了一半能用，然后砰，他让 Claude 去处理它。Claude 去学习了所有的 API，他就像，哦，确保免费做，得到了一堆
of free anyways it's up and running i don't think it's mounted on his wall yet but uh anyway the point being and and just listen it's just so refreshing i i i didn't realize sean was using it as rocket fuel. I knew he used it, but I didn't know to that extent. And anyways, we should stop spoiling the upcoming three-part interview with Sean. Yes, and you said you wanted to announce, which I agree, this is where we should do it, because by the time we mentioned in that episode, we're probably already, already in Europe at that point, we have, it's not a road trip per se, because no cars are being rented. But it is, hey, we can change that. No, no, no, no, we're not driving to, we're not driving to Collinsburg.
免费的。总之，它已经运行起来了，我不认为它已经挂在他墙上了，但，总之，重点是，而且，听着，这太令人耳目一新了。我没意识到肖恩把它当作火箭燃料使用。我知道他用它，但我不知道到那种程度。总之，我们应该停止剧透即将到来的肖恩三部分采访了。是的，你说你想宣布，我同意，这是我们应该做的地方，因为当我们在那一集中提到时，我们可能已经，在那时已经在欧洲了，我们有，这不是公路旅行，因为没有租车。但它是，嘿，我们可以改变这一点。不，不，不，不，我们不去科林斯堡。
There's a ferry. There's a ferry that you can take. I'm pretty sure there's a bridge you can take from, uh, oh, I mean, what ferry you're talking about? You can't take a talk, uh, there's a ferry from Copenhagen to Oslo. Oh, that actually wouldn't be bad. Yeah. It does take like eight hours.
有渡轮。你可以坐渡轮。我很确定有一座桥你可以从，嗯，我是说，你说的什么渡轮？你不能坐……从哥本哈根到奥斯陆有渡轮。哦，那其实不错。是的。它确实需要大约八个小时。
That's all right. If you take the night fairy, when, uh, Shima and I, uh, I don't know if I've ever said on the podcast, I know what, have I? Anyways, I proposed to Shima in Norway. and we did a big trip while we were there and at one point we were in Helsinki in Finland and we needed to go to Stockholm. I had mapped out the driving instructions
没关系。如果你坐夜间渡轮，当，希玛和我，嗯，我不知道我是否在播客上说过，我知道什么，我说过吗？总之，我在挪威向希玛求婚。
but then when we pulled into Helsinki there's a ton of what looked like cruises and then I was like I bet you can get cars on those sure enough a bunch of the cruises are just like overnight one shot things and then you skip and save like a ton of time and we didn't know what kind of cruise it was going to be if it was just going to be like a boring fair
我们在那里进行了一次大旅行，有一次我们在芬兰的赫尔辛基，我们需要去斯德哥尔摩。我绘制了驾驶路线，
or something else. But anyways, it ended up being an absolute blast because it's kind of like, it's like, I've never been on a cruise. And they've got like little... You've never been on a cruise? Never been on a cruise? And I think this one is not like the crazy Disneyland,
但当我们驶入赫尔辛基时，有大量看起来像游轮的东西，然后我就想，我打赌你可以把车开上去。果然，很多游轮只是那种过夜的一次性东西，然后你跳过并节省了大量时间。我们不知道它会是什么样的游轮，如果它只是像一个无聊的渡轮
it's a pretty old cruise, but it still had like a bunch of fun activities and pubs and restaurants and karaoke and whatnot. Anyways, I think the World Cup was on at the time and we ended up watching a Netherlands game. I can't remember if they won or lost, but it was a great time. Anyways, we are going to be,
或其他什么。但总之，它最终绝对是一次爆炸，因为它有点像，就像，我从来没坐过游轮。他们有像……你从来没坐过游轮？从来没坐过游轮？而且我认为这个不像疯狂的迪士尼乐园，
in Europe, Bryce can explain the details. We will be in our hars, near Copenhagen. You think it's our hars? I think it's Arhus. Arhus. Arhus. In Denmark, near Copenhagen. One of these.
它是一个相当古老的游轮，但它仍然有很多有趣的活动、酒吧、餐馆、卡拉 OK 之类的。总之，我想当时世界杯正在进行，我们最终看了一场荷兰队的比赛。我不记得他们是赢了还是输了，但那是一段美好的时光。总之，我们将要
We'll be in a town. The town actually where Biana went to school, we learned. We learned that a ton of programming language icons are from this little town in Denmark. And there was this article that I sent. kind of the other day about the Arhars Mafia, the Arhuis programming language mafia. What's crazy is I was watching a talk today by Casey
在欧洲，布莱斯可以解释细节。我们将会在我们的 Arhus，靠近哥本哈根。你认为它是 Arhus？我认为它是 Aarhus。Aarhus。Aarhus。在丹麦，靠近哥本哈根。其中之一。
Muratori and it was called the Big Oops as a play on like object-oriented programming and it mentions, I'm only like 10 minutes into the talk, but it mentions it like the seven minute mark that Bjarna Strewstrup was learning simula from the inventor of simula
我们将会在一个城镇。我们了解到，实际上是比雅尼（Bjarne）上学的那个城镇。我们了解到，大量的编程语言偶像都来自丹麦的这个小镇。而且有我前几天发的文章，关于 Aarhus 黑手党，Aarhus 编程语言黑手党。疯狂的是，我今天在看凯西·穆拉托里（Casey Muratori）的演讲，它叫“大 Oops”，是对面向对象编程的一种戏称，它提到了，我才看了演讲的 10 分钟，但在 7 分钟左右提到，比雅尼·斯特劳斯特鲁普（Bjarne Stroustrup）正在从 Simula 的发明者那里学习 Simula，
whose name I will not recall and it literally says Arhus on the slide. I'm like, what are the I guess it's one of those things where probably I've seen a talk where that city name is on a slide and you just don't notice it because you don't know where it is. But I wouldn't be surprised if actually this is the first time I've ever seen it in a slide deck and it just happens to be a month before I'm going to the city. Well, and so we are going to the place where it started, the place where presumably C++ start. I don't know. He probably was.
他的名字我记不起来了，幻灯片上确实写着 Aarhus。我就想，这是什么……我想这可能是那种我看过演讲，城市名字在幻灯片上，但你没注意到，因为你不知道它在哪里。但我不会感到惊讶，如果这实际上是我第一次在幻灯片中看到它，而且恰好是在我去那个城市的前一个月。好吧，所以我们要去它开始的地方，大概是 C++ 开始的地方。我不知道。他可能是在。
I'll finish watching this talk and I'll get back to you listener. It probably was because if that's where he learned simula. Yeah, you're right. If it didn't start, you know, typing-wise, it definitely started Genesis idea-wise. Because I didn't know he went to Bell Labs, which is, I think, where he started working on it. Maybe not, though.
我会看完这个演讲，然后我会回复你，听众。它可能确实是，因为如果那是他学习 Simula 的地方。是的，你是对的。如果它没有开始，你知道，打字方面，它绝对是在创世纪想法方面开始的。因为我不知道他去了贝尔实验室，我想，那是他开始研究它的地方。不过也许不是。
I think maybe it was his dissertation. We'll send him an email. We'll send him an email. We'll ask him for Ar-Hars recommendation. Ar-Hus. We'll ask him how to pronounce the name. But we will be there for the Roku Developer Summit, which is part of Roku does this, like,
我想也许那是他的论文。我们会给他发封邮件。我们会给他发封邮件。我们会问他关于 Aarhus 的建议。Aarhus。我们会问他怎么发这个名字的音。但我们将会在那里参加 Roku 开发者峰会，这是 Roku 做这个的一部分，就像，
or this Roku Engineering Symposium. It's an engineering symposium. They do this thing, and they bring in all their developers, but this part of the engineering symposium is open to the public, and Connor and I will be giving a talk, and people are welcome to come. There's a website. The link will be in the show notes with the details.
或者这个 Roku 工程研讨会。这是一个工程研讨会。他们做这个，他们把所有的开发者都带进来，但工程研讨会的这一部分是对公众开放的，康纳和我将进行演讲，欢迎大家参加。有一个网站。链接将在节目说明中，有详细信息。
And then the next day, we will be at the Copenhagen C++ Meetup, where we will also be giving talks. and then the day after that and all of this is going to be September I want to say 18th 19th 18th yeah that's correct I mean I guess that we should get the actual dates right
然后第二天，我们将参加哥本哈根 C++ 聚会，我们也会在那里进行演讲。然后在那之后的一天，所有这些都将在九月，我想说是 18 号、19 号，18 号，是的，那是正确的。我是说，我想我们应该把实际日期弄对。
it seems like it is actually correct 18th is a Thursday that's Roku day as in my calendar and then 19th is Copenhagen meetup and then from there we go to Norway to NDC Tech Town where if you dear listener want to learn from the experts how to use
看起来它实际上是正确的，18 号是星期四，那是 Roku 日，在我的日历上，然后 19 号是哥本哈根聚会，然后从那里我们去挪威参加 NDC Tech Town，如果亲爱的听众你想从专家那里学习如何使用
GPUs, how to write Kuta programs. We have not one but two full day workshops at NDC Tech Town. On September 22nd, day one, we will teach you how to write
GPU，如何编写 CUDA 程序。我们在 NDC Tech Town 有两个全天研讨会。9 月 22 日，第一天，我们将教你如何编写
modern Kuta C++. That'll be me and Connor. We have one of our colleagues, Ashwin, who will also be joining us for September 23rd, when we'll be doing a full day workshop up on Kuta Python. So you can come to IndyC Techtown, sign up for the tutorials, and learn how to be a GPU wizard in two days. You can come to one. You can come to both. I think they're both going to be great. We've got amazing content. Both workshops are very interactive. You're
现代 CUDA C++。那将是我和康纳。我们有一位同事，阿什温（Ashwin），他也会加入我们，在 9 月 23 日，我们将进行关于 CUDA Python 的全天研讨会。所以你可以来 NDC Tech Town，报名参加教程，并在两天内学习如何成为 GPU 向导。你可以来参加一个。你可以两个都参加。我想它们都会很棒。我们有很棒的内容。两个研讨会都非常互动。你
going to do a ton of exercises, but they're both no install. So we're going to do everything in this nice little web-based UI where you'll be connected to some GPU server that's on somebody's cloud somewhere, and you're going to get to write some code hands-on. It's a great course. We've taught both of them before a couple times. We've got great feedback, and I'd love to have a nice big audience for this. So please come join us. We'll have a ton of fun. And then on September 24th, I'll be giving a talk at IndyC. Techtown. And then I'm going to go home to sleep for a long period of time because that's like four or five things one after another so and uh there'll be some there'll be some podcast recording probably and uh
将做大量的练习，但它们都是免安装的。所以我们将在一个漂亮的基于 Web 的 UI 中完成所有事情，你将连接到某人云端的某个 GPU 服务器，你将亲手编写一些代码。这是一门很棒的课程。我们之前已经教过这两门课几次了。我们得到了很好的反馈，我很乐意为这个课程拥有一个庞大的观众群。所以请加入我们。我们会玩得很开心。然后在 9 月 24 日，我将在 NDC Tech Town 进行演讲。然后我要回家睡很长一段时间，因为那是一个接一个的四五件事，所以，而且，可能会有一些播客录音，
we should have ADSP stickers I was just going to say Bryce sometimes we are it is crazy I've said this the last time we recorded too where you were saying one thing and I was like that's literally what was in my brain not only was in my brain they're in my hand they weren't just sitting on my desk I had them in my hand ready to say and not only will you be able to chat with us. I'm sure there'll be some socials and stuff outside of the training. But for the first time ever, thanks to Bryce, it's actually been on my list of things to do for like three years.
我们应该有 ADSP 贴纸。我正要说，布莱斯，有时我们……这太疯狂了。我上次录音时也说过，你说了一件事，我就想，那简直就在我脑子里。不仅在我脑子里，它们就在我手里。它们不只是放在我的桌子上，我手里拿着它们准备说。而且不仅你将能够和我们聊天。我相信在培训之外会有一些社交活动之类的。但这是有史以来第一次，多亏了布莱斯，它实际上已经在我的待办事项清单上三年了。
I think we brought it up probably 10 times on this podcast. Multiple times. It's come up so many times. But the problem is I actually did talk to a sticker guy. And anyways, but we have, I think there's nine here. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven. All right. They said they sent me 10, or maybe it was 12.
我想我们在播客上提过大概 10 次了。多次。它提过很多次了。但问题是我确实和一个贴纸商谈过。总之，但我们有，我想这里有九个。一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八、九、十、十一。好了。他们说他们寄给我 10 个，或者也许是 12 个。
But so I have 11 at least. I'm imagining Bryce is going to order more, but... Yeah, I'm going to do a full production. But if he doesn't, folks, I will be bringing 11 stickers. I have the 12th one on my laptop right now. So if Bryce fails to order these or they don't show up in time, there are going to be only 11. And I guess if there's 11, we'll have to, like, come up with some kind of quiz.
但所以至少我有 11 个。我设想布莱斯会订购更多，但……是的，我会做一个完整的生产。但如果他不这样做，伙计们，我会带 11 个贴纸。我现在笔记本电脑上有一个第 12 个。所以如果布莱斯没能订购这些或者它们没能及时出现，将只有 11 个。我想如果有 11 个，我们不得不，比如，想出某种测验。
And that's... No, no, no, no, I already ordered them. They'll definitely be here. However, those are like the pre-production ones, so maybe we can give away, we can give away those ones specifically. Oh, yeah, yeah. I just have to remember to find the, right.
那是……不，不，不，不，我已经订购了。它们肯定会在这里。然而，那些是预生产的，所以也许我们可以送出，我们可以专门送出那些。哦，是的，是的。我只需要记得找到，对。
They're probably going to look the same, though, no? Or did you make a slight change? The thing is, we did multiple different... You said you'd be able to tell, though, because you had it on file. Bryce ordered a bunch of different styles and then sent me one, and then I was like, ah, it looks pretty good.
它们看起来可能是一样的，不是吗？或者你做了轻微的改动？问题是，我们做了多个不同的……你说过你能分辨出来，因为你有存档。布莱斯订购了一堆不同的款式，然后寄给我一个，然后我就想，啊，看起来不错。
It's a little bit dark for the red, but you know what this is why we didn't have stickers for four years because we're like oh you know it needs to be right but uh it's close enough but then bryce was like oh so what's the number on the package and i was like i tossed that like the second i got them man or recycled it it would have been like a last little sticker though but let's see i i i think i'm getting pretty close to i'm trying to find i got multiple order numbers here too many order numbers yeah anyways folks we've got it's going to be a great time because when i feel like there was uh go back to the episode lists oh yeah oh yeah that's right we were both at c plus plus under the sea
红色有点暗，但你知道吗，这就是为什么我们四年没有贴纸，因为我们想，哦，你知道，它需要是正确的，但它足够接近了，但布莱斯说，哦，包装上的数字是多少，我就想，我一拿到它们就把它扔了，伙计，或者回收了。那本来是一个最后的小贴纸，但让我们看看，我想我快要……我正在尝试找到，我这里也有多个订单号，太多的订单号。是的，总之，伙计们，我们有……这将是一段美好的时光，因为当我感觉有……回到剧集列表，哦，是的，哦，是的，没错，我们都在 C++ Under the Sea。
so we kind of do have like an annual we had the the slovenia road trip in 2023 and then which will be probably hard to ever be topped then we had the c plus plus under the sea uh last year in 2024 and now we're going to be at nDC tech town in norway um in september uh this time we're going to have stickers and it's going to be a oh yeah and that's the other thing is that we are working towards open sourcing uh the library that i've been working on for the last while yeah i don't want to say anything about it i think it's safe enough to say it's a actually i won't say anything but anyways we're working towards open sourcing it on the mvs um github and maybe by the time this is actually airing in a week or two uh it might already be out there and so hopefully i'll
所以我们确实有像年度……我们在 2023 年有斯洛文尼亚公路旅行，然后，那可能很难被超越，然后我们去年在 2024 年参加了 C++ Under the Sea，现在我们将在九月参加挪威的 NDC Tech Town，这次我们将有贴纸，而且这将是一个……哦，是的，那是另一件事，我们正在努力开源我最近一直在做的库。是的，我不想说任何关于它的事，我想说它是一个……其实我什么都不会说，但总之，我们正在努力在 MVS GitHub 上开源它，也许当它在一两周后播出时，它可能已经发布了，所以希望我会……
be able to talk about it in the presentations that I'm giving. You think you can say the name? I don't want to, because the name could change at like the 11th hour. And so I don't want to say that yet. But I will say, actually, let me quickly share my screen before you go, Bryce. It is because I had, well, I have to be very vague about this. I had a emoji as the logo of the library, but then there are some copyright rules that you could run into by using the.
能够在我的演讲中谈论它。你觉得你能说出它的名字吗？我不想说，因为名字可能会在最后一刻改变。所以我还不想说。但我会说，实际上，在我走之前，让我快速分享一下我的屏幕，Bryce。这是因为我，好吧，我必须对此非常含糊。我曾用一个表情符号作为库的标志，但使用它可能会遇到一些版权规则。
emoji itself because this emoji I preferred the Microsoft one and so in fact if I go get you the what do you call it emoji and then we can't say what emoji because that gives away the name of the library but if we go
表情符号本身，因为这个表情符号我更喜欢微软的那一个，所以实际上如果我去给你找那个，你叫它什么来着，表情符号，然后我们不能说是什么表情符号，因为那会泄露库的名字，但如果我们去
But the name of the library is something that is an emoji yeah so look if you go to this one that's clearly not the emoji rendering I want because for folks that know there's like a bajillion different that that is an ugly version of the thing that the library is. The one that I like
但库的名字是一个表情符号，是的，所以你看，如果你去这个，那显然不是我想要的表情符号渲染，因为对于了解的人来说，有成千上万种不同的，那是一个丑陋的版本，不是这个库的东西。我喜欢的那一个
is the Microsoft 2021 flat. That is a much more attractive one of the thing. But unfortunately, you can't use these emojis as like logos and stuff. Anyways, Michael, my boss was like,
是微软2021年的扁平化版本。那是更吸引人的一个。但不幸的是，你不能把这些表情符号当作标志之类的东西使用。总之，我的老板Michael说，
yeah, you got to change the logo. So what did I do? I just went to Gemini and then said, hey, I want the same? It's not a logo. It's not a logo. It's a graphic signifier.
是的，你得换个标志。所以我做了什么？我只是去了Gemini，然后说，嘿，我想要一样的？这不是标志。这不是标志。这是一个图形标识符。
And I said, I really like this. emoji but I want it to be different so I said just make it with it
我说，我真的很喜欢这个表情符号，但我希望它有所不同，所以我说只要用它做出来就行
oh shit you're gonna have to bleep that one just make it slightly different and sure I'll bleep that out and I mean
哦该死，你得把那个消音，只要让它稍微不同一点，当然我会把它消音，我的意思是
actually I did this with both Gemini 2.5 I think Flash and then chat GPT 5 and the chat GPT one I wonder if I can find
实际上我用Gemini 2.5（我想是Flash版本）和ChatGPT 5都试过了，ChatGPT的那个，我不知道能不能找到
it in history it is terrible Yeah, I know it's so bad Let's see Dun dun dun Oh yeah Yeah yeah I do have it Can you uh
在历史记录里，它太糟糕了。是的，我知道它太烂了。让我们看看，噔噔噔，哦是的，是的，我确实有它。你能，呃
I've lost This one This is so wait I've lost oh yeah It looks like a It looks like a haunted version Of the thing Yeah
我丢了，这个，这个，等等，我丢了，哦是的，它看起来像一个，它看起来像一个闹鬼版本的那个东西，是的
And that's the thing is It's they both They both technically like For what I requested They both met the goal But just like Look at this one it's yeah like it's haunted because it's not using white it looks dead and uh whereas this one
这就是问题所在，它们两个，从技术上讲，对于我所要求的，它们都达到了目标，但就像，看看这个，是的，它看起来像闹鬼，因为它没有使用白色，它看起来死气沉沉的，而这一个
this one looks cute as hell like it does it makes me but it also doesn't it doesn't really look like that's all right thing it just people can tell what category of thing this is correct people can tell what category of thing that's all we need that's all we need that's all we need although it looks like it looks like a thing that you would have at an I'm going to, we got a, we got a, I'm going to have to peep, beep that out because that's too, that's too much information. Anyways, folks, I'm going to stop presenting, um, look forward to the Sean parent trilogy. Or did they call it a trilogy?
这一个看起来可爱极了，它确实让我，但它也不，它看起来不太像那个东西，没关系，人们能看出这是什么类别的东西，没错，人们能看出这是什么类别的东西，这就是我们需要的一切，这就是我们需要的一切，尽管它看起来像一个你会有的东西，我打算，我们得，我们得，我得把那个消音，因为那太，那信息量太大了。总之，各位，我要停止演示了，期待Sean Parent三部曲。或者他们称之为三部曲吗？
Yeah, we'll call it a trilogy. Trilogy of episodes. Any final thoughts before you go, buddy? Oh, no. Well, um, yes, yes. Oh, he does have a final thought. I have, I have, I have the three top. that we'll talk about on a future podcast.
是的，我们称之为三部曲。剧集三部曲。在你走之前还有什么最后的想法吗，伙计？哦，没有。好吧，嗯，是的，是的。哦，他确实有一个最后的想法。我有，我有，我有前三名，我们会在以后的播客中讨论。
Oh, yes. And to interrupt Bryce, because he's about to mention some algorithm topics. The reason I said, it's one, it's going to be exciting to be able to talk about the library I've been working on. But two, there's a bunch of algorithmic conversations that are going to come out of open sourcing this and being able to talk about it. Yeah. But the thing that I was talking about, I'm not sure if it was actually on air or if
哦，是的。打断一下Bryce，因为他正要提到一些算法话题。我之所以说，第一，能够谈论我一直在开发的库会很令人兴奋。但第二，开源这个库并能够谈论它会引出一堆算法对话。是的。但我刚才谈论的事情，我不确定它是否真的在直播中，或者
it was before air where, yeah, I was mentioning the thrust GitHub repo search and then the algorithm that was in paddle, paddle, paddle or whatever that. repo was. It was a, yeah, a matrix row-wise mode. There was a bunch of interesting stuff behind that and also this algorithm called replicate. Just put that on your list of things that we have to talk about. And yeah, I'll explain what replicate is and we can dedicate a whole. But anyways, there's been a bunch of like, if folks are worrying what happened to our algorithm podcast. It's now just an AI podcast. The algorithms are going to make a comeback. Your screen is frozen. Are you still there? Bryce is back. He left. He's back. He's back. He's back.
是在直播前，是的，我提到了Thrust GitHub仓库搜索，然后是Paddle、Paddle、Paddle或者那个仓库里的算法。那是一个，是的，矩阵行模式。那背后有一堆有趣的东西，还有这个叫replicate的算法。把它列入我们必须讨论的事情清单中。是的，我会解释什么是replicate，我们可以专门用一整期来讨论。但总之，有一堆，如果大家担心我们的算法播客发生了什么。它现在只是一个AI播客。算法将会卷土重来。你的屏幕冻结了。你还在吗？Bryce回来了。他离开了。他回来了。他回来了。他回来了。
but anyways, replicate algorithms, the three things that you have on deck to talk about. Yes, teaser for future episodes. These were just three notes that I wrote down like six months ago, and every month I've been getting like an email reminder. And so I'm going to mention them so that we'll be forced to talk about them. The first, parallel rotate and parallel rolling reduce are related. Some of you might remember my ramblings about rolling reduce a few years ago, which we're going to have to talk about again because I've discovered some new use cases for rolling reduce.
但总之，replicate算法，你准备讨论的三件事。是的，未来剧集的预告。这只是我六个月前写下的三条笔记，每个月我都会收到一封电子邮件提醒。所以我提一下它们，这样我们就会被迫讨论它们。第一，并行旋转和并行滚动归约是相关的。你们中有些人可能还记得我几年前关于滚动归约的唠叨，我们必须再次讨论它，因为我发现了一些滚动归约的新用例。
I've come up with an even better algorithm for rolling reduce. So stay tuned. And Phineas, and Phineas, we are going to bring you back on to talk about the thing we were going to talk about. He posted, he sent us a message, maybe he was on GitHub or something.
我想出了一个更好的滚动归约算法。所以敬请期待。还有Phineas，Phineas，我们会请你回来谈谈我们要谈的事情。他发帖了，他给我们发了一条消息，也许是在GitHub上或其他什么地方。
Anyways, we're going to have Phineas back on. There's much to talk about with him. Adjacent difference is the inverse of a scan. We've talked about that on the pod. You have forgot him. But we'll talk about it again. Did we?
总之，我们会请Phineas回来。和他有很多要谈的。邻接差是扫描的逆运算。我们在播客上谈过这个。你已经忘了。但我们会再谈一次。我们谈过吗？
Did we? Okay. We'll talk about it again. Christabella, if we forget to bring up Christabella when they talk about that, That'll be a sin of omission because his name should be mentioned. This last one is just a, it's really more work because I need it for something in NVIDIA, but can you shuffle with a scan?
我们谈过吗？好吧。我们会再谈一次。Christabella，如果我们谈论那个时忘了提到Christabella，那将是遗漏之罪，因为应该提到他的名字。最后这一项只是一个，它实际上更多是工作，因为我在NVIDIA需要它，但你能用扫描进行洗牌吗？
I thought you could, but then I looked at some more. I'm not so sure. Maybe with an exclusive scan, but not necessarily with an inclusive scan. Those are the three things, the three things. So if anybody stay tuned, but in an infinity, Anybody who's got any thoughts or ideas about those. You know how to communicate with us on the interwebs. Yeah.
我以为可以，但我看了更多资料。我不确定。也许用独占扫描可以，但不一定能用包含扫描。这就是那三件事，那三件事。所以如果有人敬请期待，但在无限中，任何对这些有想法或主意的人。你知道如何在互联网上与我们交流。是的。
All right, I got to go because if we don't leave for the U.S. Open now, we're not going to be on time, and then Ramona's going to throw me off the train or something. All right. And watch out, folks. I've been inspired by some AI podcasts I'm listening to. I think we're going to start dipping our toe in the shorts world. And that's not the shorts you wear. That's the shorts on the inner webs.
好吧，我得走了，因为如果我们现在不出发去美国公开赛，我们就赶不上了，然后Ramona会把我从火车上扔下去什么的。好吧。各位小心，我受到我正在听的一些AI播客的启发。我想我们要开始涉足短视频领域了。那不是你穿的短裤。那是互联网上的短视频。
We're going to potentially start an Instagram, ADSP, a key. account, a TikTok ADSP account, and maybe even a YouTube ADSP account. YouTube shorts. That's what I watch. I watch the YouTube shorts. And yeah, so, you know, we're trying to, it's a new, it's a brave new world. We're trying to, we're trying to grow our reach. Mixed media formats. Mixed media formats. Yeah. And the goal is that in the future, the AI is just going to do it all for us. And just so we're going to get the ball rolling. And, yeah, anyways, we're letting Bryce go. Enjoy the tennis. And we will chat soon. I'll chat with you later.
我们可能会开始一个Instagram ADSP账号，一个TikTok ADSP账号，甚至可能是一个YouTube ADSP账号。YouTube短视频。那就是我看的。我看YouTube短视频。是的，所以，你知道，我们正在尝试，这是一个新的，勇敢的新世界。我们正在尝试，我们正在尝试扩大我们的影响力。混合媒体格式。混合媒体格式。是的。目标是未来AI会为我们做这一切。所以我们只是要让事情开始运转。而且，是的，总之，我们让Bryce走了。享受网球比赛。我们很快会再聊。我稍后再和你聊。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。